こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんお水飲まれるでしょうか
まあ少なからずもう人間だとしたらお水を飲むことがあると思うんですけども
どうせ now なぁうまい水の方がいいですよねでき軍なことにもですね私肇社長の
地元とこの色はずのとれた場所の地元が一緒なんです
僕肇社長もこの色あせボディ
出身地が砺波市富山県の店みって同じ場所なんですよ
まあ僕の水を飲む機会があるんですけどもどうせ飲むんだったら地元の甘え水がの見て
ということで何か美味しい水を攻略に飲む方法はないのかと思ったところ私はひらめい
てしまいました部活やってる方とかなんか体育館とかでよく見るあのあれわかります
でしょ
彼らのをしたら出てくるアレですそしたら女ってあるじゃんって
彼らが別れたいるんですけどあれじゃあなまだとこ水道水が出てくるんですけどもなん
か改造してその中身よりロスの水に帰ると押せだけでどこでも地元の水が伸びるんじゃ
ないかという事で今回は畑がいる
2号室の部屋においしい屋根を設置していきましょう
うめぇ
おっこういったわけですよねいきなり9されに暴れてしまったんですけど
いや本社機ですよたことないんだからねたんですけど
ご覧くださいこれで見たことあるんですよはいカットがよく見るし
そうだねそれが見たのがあると思うんですけどもこれがいいんやったらマジで便利だと
思うんですよ
水の量じゃないですかそうさらにその中の店が色あせられずこれは杖までも
ていきましょういきまーす覚え
に4
[音楽]
開いてきてここらへんにこの子おこうと思うんですけども
このまま普通に使うと水道水の水が出るんですけどちょっぴり改造していろはすの水が
出るようにしようと思いますそしてこちらに今回使う色圧を受診していただきました
このれあれば多分素早くが出ると思うんで大丈夫だと思いますそしてこちらに並べいろ
はすは全部僕なぜほど店見てとれた水を使っておりますつまりこれを設置すればいつで
も私の地元た波で採れたいろはすが飲めるということでございます息セッティングして
いきましょう
安全トレ
作れるとっ
4日
キルゴアすげー切ります
ああ
[音楽]
水ってこれだとこうなんか降らせる管内で
と夏帆のポンプを使ってかけていろはすの水が出るようにするらしいです
よしきました
アイドルプレ5人ニック的には完成ですがここが普通の水ですもねその見てくるところ
おこう
いろは数は入れて流し込んでポンプで押し出してやって感じです早速動かしてみ
ましょう
入ってゆけ形は完全したので後実際にこの体育館のこれに
水が行く所にいろはすを入れていきますどんなにできます
やばいのメッ3時間かかるなああっ
[音楽]
よしタブこれくらいで大蔵不本意です
あとは組んで出したりしてるなんか出るまで頑張る
ます
これでますまあまあん
きてれてるぞ
[音楽]
入れ家五
新品みたいでちょっとお菓子みたいですね今ちょっとやってもらってるっていう手も来
てますねこれ
完全によってした
エアロックっていうのはあのー途中に空気が入ってでパンツが買わなければここを
やろうと全部はすげー
インストラリアの
もうずに頑張ると出てくるみたいです僕はそれどうしてくれます
[音楽]
ていた
普通に女が早いますねんねぇ
はっはっはっん
ん
うん
んん
待って待って待って待ってパパ on どっかのれないですけど確実に出てきてはい
ません
あ
ゆえにムラがありますねこれくらいですああ
バッハ論具合 web でネイルねー
あとゲップ出てきた
毛利時なんだよまだちょっと空気が溜まってる感じがしますよね
えええええええ
すごいもう車
[音楽]
ああああああ
地元の水目
指で色あせ投げる体育館とか自分の歯でよく見るアレが完成しましたーー
ああああああ
はいというわけで無事色あせが出る体育館とかジムとかで夢られの完成でございますで
これけっこうヤバイと思うんだよね
やってエンジンにつれで色はずが飲めるわけですから
まあここが続く限りというわけでもう菅田の畑のみんなが帰ってくると思うのでみんな
でおいしい水を取りうまければいいなと思っておりますではみんなの党者が間違っ
ちゃう
goo ん
を
[音楽]
持った
goo
を
[音楽]
goo ん
goo
ポッん
[音楽]
バッハ
ん
えっ
えっなにこれである格好レベルやつですよね
高
ブーツ
なぜ3ねいえこれでですかコレイルはそれ抜きに出るんだよ
マジっすかうぬ外に出るんですけどねえ
まあ本当ならすごい
うめぇ
ん
a子シーリー入って上で今回はですね
いろは数をオータークーラーに入れてみましたあの水が続く限り a にいろは背が
伸び続けることができますで実はですねこちらのイロハする日本の天然水で全国7カ所
であっ初でした
全国7カ所で採水されているみたいですって皆さんとか疑問
思うんですよ自分はどこのイロハず飲んでるんだろうと思うと思うんですけども
自分のエリア日開催生地の色長谷が届いているらしいですねこのな中その際生地って
いうのが全国に散らばるようにありましてこちらが北海道岩手県の奥羽山脈
山梨の白秋私が地元テーマ県の砺波
鳥取の大山熊本の阿蘇進み
矢崎のエビのになっておりますで僕静岡に住んでるんで食べ山梨の白秋のいろはすを
いつも飲んでると思います今回はた並みの水の色髪を使ってですねいつでも俺の地元の
水が飲めるようにしてみました
ああいう競技で皆さんいろはセグ今度7種類もあると思わなかったと思うので是非
色褪せぬ際はどこの水かなとか考えながら飲んでみるのも楽しいかもしれない
全ねぜひ皆さんもいろはす飲んでみてくださいじゃあなー
me
ana あああっ